[Music]
all right today's question comes from
jane in wisconsin my daughter is 15 and
has recently experienced some mental
health challenges i'm concerned about
her ability to manage the money her
grandparents have been investing for i
currently manage the account but it will
transfer to her when she turns 16.
should i
allow the account to transfer to her but
hide the login details
or transfer the money into my name until
she turns 21.
both feel morally wrong and maybe
illegal
is there a legal way to ensure she can't
access it until she's 21.
so dave my
i just operating rules never lie to your
kids
um
this is complex because her child's
obviously struggling with some
challenges here um i don't know the
legality
you've probably seen this question more
than i have um i don't know why you can
hide something that
transfers to a kid but also this kid's a
minor yeah so it doesn't transfer to the
kid
you're confused somewhere okay um
all bank accounts all mutual funds uh
for people under 21 have a custodian on
them
an adult
or 18 or 21
18 21 depending on the state whatever
but i mean you're you're not 21 if it's
mutual funds um you're not
able to enter into contract law which
opening a savings account is in any
state in the union when you're not an
adult there you go
and so
now the
trust may transfer to her the
uh whatever but she doesn't suddenly
become the owner of a million dollars
and 16 years old or whatever this amount
of money is it just doesn't happen now
but i'm with john just tell her the
truth
hey i'm walking with you through these
mental health things
and you don't need the pressure of this
right now the money is yours it'll be
there for you you'll have access to it
when you are healthy and you are able to
make good decisions with it and like
when you're an adult
nobody's going to do anything with it
i'm not buying me a new car with it i'm
not doing anything like that the money's
there it's yours sweetie it's okay and
it may be only a thousand dollars i
don't know what it is we don't know from
this and sometimes people get it in
their head there's a lot of money it's
not immoral and it's not illegal to care
for your children they're minors
it's immoral and
to not care for your children or to hand
somebody who's struggling a million
dollars yeah it's not ethical now if she
was 23
now you've got all kinds of issues
well you really don't have anything more
money moral and legal
i mean you but you you can't do that
then you just you just have to talk to
you you could say
you could offer to
become her power of attorney until she
gets well but that you do that for your
friend who's 32 also you know and so
but but you've got a minor here and
they just um they have a right to
uh
uh ethical treatment they have a right
to nurturing they have a right to
nutrition they have a right to not be
abused but they don't have
have ownership rights
as minors right um
my car
by the three-year-old is not actually a
true statement
well and i i think we forget sometimes
dave
had this negotiation with one of
rachel's the other day i imagine but
we've all agreed as a society
um we think you should be 16 before you
get behind a 3 000 pound metal missile
headed down the highway we uh let's
let's wait till you're 18. let's wait
till you're 21 for some of these
but then we turn around and we just ask
kids to make so many heavy decisions or
what do you want to do when you're 15
years old or 14 years old
man they need adults in their lives to
help keep them well it's okay it's okay
to uh
have give them information but not the
weight right
yeah i'm gonna carry this for you it's
gonna be here for you when you need it
yeah
but you don't get to you know you're not
going to go buy
a 50 000 car because grandma gave you a
hundred thousand bucks right you're not
gonna do it and because you're not
capable of making that decision and so
someone will be assigned as the
custodian
until she's 18. there's currently
someone
i currently manage the account but it
will transfer to her when she turns 16.
um
i don't know where you got your
information jane but something's
confused here hey let me ask you this if
she took that money and rolled it into a
529 is that a way to shelter it from her
kid and save it for college
i don't know what the source of the
money is okay and whether uh whether
that's gonna be okay i i i just think
you just say no yeah i don't like
stealing i don't like you're doing
heroin and i'm not giving you any money
yeah sue me
you know
and if you want to if you want to
you know go live somewhere else or
whatever and you want to get a lawyer
then you can do that i guess but um but
i'm not giving you i'm not going to
assist you in harming yourself yeah
and you know misusing this money is
harming you and the future you and i
just love you too much to let you do
that and so
you know another version of that we
always said was
uh we had
uniform transfer to miners act
which was before there were 529's that's
how you save money it's just all that
means is you open a mutual fund in the
kid's name but you're the custodian just
like we're talking about
and uh parents would say always say well
i don't know i mean my kid turned 16 or
turns 21 i mean what if they're doing
heroin i would just go well technically
you're 21 it's their money i guess
they've got a well financed heroin
addiction or you can just look at them
and go find it
i'm stealing it
you know that's technically illegal
right but i mean what am i gonna do i'm
gonna take care of my child
and if some of you don't like it screw
it yeah you know i'm doing it anyway so
no i'm not gonna let you kill yourself
because i saved money for you
that's dumb
so uh and sometimes the culture is dumb
call dhs everybody does so why not you
know why not you too so um you know have
at it baby good luck with that let's see
how it turns out for you you're still
none of you're gonna find it because i'm
the only one got the codes
and so
and i'm just that guy you know because i
just i'm just gonna it was my money to
start with right that i gave you and now
we're not going to let you you know so
you just kind of have to have the old
school parent idea of like i'm in charge
right and i'm and i'm going to love you
even when it's hard
yeah the inmates don't run the freaking
asylum at the ramses